[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur audition
publique cette semaine est à nouveau et
ont tenté dia décisive pour le
gouvernement elle est tout à fait pour
cette nouvelle assemblée nationale qui
verra ses postes clés attribué à
commencer par l'élection du président la
présidente de l'assemblée ce sera demain
elisabeth borg el premier ministre
consulte pour trouver tenter de trouver
les moyens de gouverner elle reçoit les
groupes politiques ces jours-ci depuis
d'ailleurs cet après midi jusqu'à demain
que lui direz vous m'envoyez marc l'ex
jours merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
président du groupe lr vous succédez à
damien abad à la tête d'un groupe
d'opposition plus modestes 60e combien
de 162 ouvrira demain demain ce sera
fixé définitivement
61,62 un groupe plus modestes mais nous
direz vous peut être plus central on
verra politiquement parlant comment
travailler au service des français dans
cette configuration
étrange en tout cas inédite la france
est-elle ingouvernable vous en débattre
et avec le sénateur françois patriat
macro nist historique dans une
quarantaine de minutes quelles sont vos
propositions olivier malek sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur l'urgence sanitaire
qui va venir aussi à l'assemblée on en
saura plus grâce à brigitte boucher et
tam tran huy dans quelques instants la
bataille pour le parti se profile aussi
le parti a l'air
yves traire sera face à vous juste après
mais d'abord quelques instants avant
d'ouvrir j'allais dire les hostilités
non les questions d'actualité vous avez
51 ans l'évier marc l'ex vous êtes
député de vous confirmer je faisais
député d'eure-et-loir depuis 2012
j'avais déjà fait deux mandats vous
aviez soutenu michel barnier à la
primaire
votre élection à la tête du groupe
serait une victoire dit on pour laurent
wauquiez je pense que c'est une question
que vous sur laquelle vous reviendrez
avec yves thréard vous revendiquez vous
dites vous même être anti macron est sur
une ligne dure sheller je savoir d'abord
si ça me correspond et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire exactement
ligne dure non je me reconnais pas
particulièrement là dedans en tout cas
je suis dans pas partisan delà de la
confusion avec le président de la
république parce que simplement je
partage pas son son sa vision du monde
je veux dire son projet parce que son
projet dabo coup fluctuer à travers le
temps et on peut pas dire que la
dernière élection présidentielle est
permis de beaucoup de clarifier mais moi
ce que j'ai observé du précédent
quinquennat ce qu'on avait un président
qui était globalement
un mondialiste quelqu'un pour qui
oki finalement qu'une entreprise sur
anciens
du monde une vision
c'est le constat la vision du grand
marché mondial auquel il faut toujours
s'ouvrir davantage qu'une entreprise
soit française ou étrangère ça n'a pas
d'importance à ses yeux la lavande
d'alstom la vente d'alcatel
sujet sur lequel j'ai prise d'une
commission d' enquête
peut pas dire qu'ils attachent beaucoup
d'importance aux frontières général
regardez regardant les résultats sa
politique d'immigration qui est plus
désastreuse que celle d' que celle de
françois hollande auparavant encore
c'est un exploit donc voilà un président
très très ouvert sur sur le monde c'est
un choix c'est pas le mien moi je pense
que le pouvoir il est fait pour protéger
les français pour les pour les pour les
protéger sur un plan économique mais
aussi sur un plan évidemment d'autres
s'abriter en termes de contrôle de
l'immigration et puis il compense tout
ça
cette grande ouverture sur le marché
mondial par de la redistribution en fait
c'est totalement les tests dans la main
que 10 à dire 20 ans tout ça donc de la
redistribution sans fin regardez pour
lui la réponse à tout s'est toujours
systématiquement de la dépense publique
ça se termine toujours à la fin pour
parler et donc on est là aussi pour
teapot de 7,2 cette vision
cette vision cette façon de gouverner le
pays 17 d'argent public à tour de bras
depuis qu'on a plus anti macron c'est
très clair vous avez dit en quelques
mots il a été réélu à 58% ce que jamais
personne n'avait réussi sous la vème
république et vous dit hier ont confié
au jdd que cette assemblée et sans
majorité vous avez oublié un mot
majorité absolue oui oui enfin de sa
majorité elle et sa majorité absolue on
a une à une mais plus que des minorités
gouvernementales
dans une situation inédite qui va
pas se battre mais c'est parce que vous
êtes
à pied il a une majorité à l'assemblée
il a une majorité pour le moins inédite
par son par sa petitesse et apprenez
c'est quand même c'était important de
faire ce constat certes il a été réélu
cet
exploit personnel sans précédent si on
pense qu'on est dans la performance
sportive
mais la réalité derrière c'est que les
prix des français show du peuple
français a été de ne pas lui donner de
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
et de l'obliger à
agou enfin légiférer en écoutant un peu
plus les différents représentants des
français pensent
les français veulent qu'il partage le
pouvoir oui c'est le message que je
n'aime que je retiens de ces de cette
élection c'est à dire que les français
nous met tous d'ailleurs face à nos
responsabilités le lui lui président de
la république en disant en clair on veut
que tu as hâte de faire ton petit chef
et de tout décider tout seul
et et vous les députés ben voilà on va
on va voir que vous être capable est ce
que vous êtes capable de travailler
ensemble c'est une responsabilité qu'il
faut qu'il faut entendre de part et
d'autre hamou de la commission des
finances on va entrer ensuite avec
brigitte et et etam sur des questions
aussi très précise la commission des
finances alors c'est très important
l'assemblée nationale quelques groupes
de savoir quel groupe va présider la
commission des finances elle devrait
échoir au rassemblement national si l'on
s'en tient aux règles c'est en gros ce
qu'a dit gérard larcher le président du
sénat la semaine dernière ce que vous
êtes sur cette ligne
oui à la tradition c'est qu'elle revient
au principal groupe d'opposition qui
numériquement est si on parle des
groupes déclaré à l'assemblée nationale
et de rassemblement national la nuque
n'étant qu'un intergroupe dont la france
a soumises et le plus gros élément avec
je crois 75 75 députés à l'heure à
laquelle nous parlons on connaît pas
encore les effectifs de
nous disposerons les groupes très
précisément au sein des hausses en donne
à plat les rapports de force on sait que
le rassemblement national ce tour de 89
82 au sein de chaque humain et au sein
de chaque commission on ne sait pas
effectivement comment ça va se passer
boutique rue c'est parce que le vote est
un certain c'est que ça réellement le
rapport de forces sur cette commission
voilà ce qui est sûr c'est que le
jalel à la nuque aurait pu faire qui y
revendique aussi cette présidence aurait
pu faire un choix sans doute un peu plus
consensuel en présentant quelqu'un comme
valérie rabault wii et qui s'est retiré
aujourd'hui extrêmement estimé à
l'assemblée nationale ça aurait été
différent c'est pas le choix je pense
que ces élections de présidents de
commissions c'est une élection qui se
fait toujours en petit comité par les
membres de la commission par les
commissaires qui sont des gens qui se
connaissent que l'habitude de travailler
ensemble et qu'ils choisissent l'un des
leurs en fonction aussi de sa capacité à
s'extraire un peu de son étiquette
politique et d'exercer sa présidence de
manière
alors suite ans dans la peau du
personnage comme quand on préside
l'assemblée nationale on n'est pas le
représentant la partie on président
toute l'assemblée nationale doit se
respecter par tous le choix de leur
candidat effectivement être un choix un
peu un peu plus polémique et évidemment
ce qui veut dire que cette élection sera
un choix sans doute un peu quand les
liens pour les membres de la commission
et peut-être dureront pas l'air on y
reviendra parce que vous vous
présenterez
et on verra si vous pourriez
éventuellement
laisser enfin la faire se retirer ou 2e
ou au 3e tour on y reviendra tout à
l'heure un cc l'ingénierie parlementaire
mais ça nous intéresse on va tout de
suite rejoindre pas ce qui nous attend
vincent roux en direct du figaro live
bonsoir mon cher vincent
merci
vincent roux va vous soumettre deux
questions d'actualité laquelle est la
première belle et très importante
vincent les couve à leurs questions la
première c'est celle qui a été soulevée
ce week-end de par votre homologue de la
république en marche aurore bergé qui
propose
en tous les cas qui parle de proposer
une loi qui inscrirait le droit à
l'avortement dans la constitution alors
y êtes-vous favorable et si elle était
présentée est ce que l air vautrer ou
bien est-ce que vous êtes plutôt
d'accord et que françois bayrou en
pensant que c'est une mauvaise idée que
ce n'est pas là la place de la
constitution ou encore pascal perrineau
ce soit qu'ils disent et que si on fait
ça bien les députés ne me servent plus à
rien et tout c'est le gouvernement des
juges
oui je crois d'abord que si on pouvait
s'éviter systématiquement d'importer en
france tous les débats américains
je pense que pour s'intéresser à nos
problèmes on se reportera sur doute pas
plus mal la société américaine d'une
société s'est radicalement différente de
la nôtre ceux ci étaient beaucoup plus
religieuse ou ce débat d'ailleurs n'a
jamais été tranchée par par les
représentants du du peuple ce n'est pas
une loi du congrès qui a autorisé le
l'avortement mais c'était une décision
de la cour suprême dans ce contexte est
radicalement différent
ça n'est pas le nôtre j'observe
d'ailleurs que que que madame berger a
eu tort de se précipiter puisque tout ça
a permis quand même de faire de montrer
à tout le monde l'absence de valeurs de
la république en marche puisque la
république en marche a eu l'occasion de
constitutionnaliser
le droit à l'avortement 2018 dans un
débat de fond de révision de la
constitution dont il était l initiative
il ya eu un amendement de la france a
soumises de mémoire sur ce sujet ils
l'ont refusée vous et vous est ce que
vous êtes pour
ça peut pour dire que avant de faire du
buzz voilà faut bien de s'interroger sur
sur ses valeurs et que la question de
l'avortement est un sujet qui mérite
beaucoup mieux que du buzz sur le fond
sur le fond de choses
j'essaie j'aurais quand même rappeler
que c'est la droite qui est à l'origine
dans ce pays de la législation
permettant légalisant l'ivg y est c'est
le président giscard d'estaing qu'il a
voulu dans son programme sur premier
ministre s'appelait jacques chirac et la
loi a été porté par par simone veil pour
nous ça fait partie de notre patrimoine
juridique sans aucune source aucune
équivoque et du défendront ivg s'il
était menacé ça n'a jamais été le cas
dans notre pays je pense qu'en quarante
quelques années de de vie parlementaire
personne n'a jamais ouvert ce débat donc
effectivement le leu leu leu je pense
que tout ce buzz est totalement inutile
et ne répondent pas à l'urgence des
français en matière d'avortement moi je
pense que motivé j'ai je pense que vous
dites c'est que ça n'est pas une urgence
pour les français donc ça n'est pas la
peine de se précipiter
dans demain hergé devrait se préoccuper
de l'insuffisance du nombre de médecins
gynécologues par exemple qui font que
dès que des jeunes femmes ont des
difficultés à consulter notamment dans
les délais c'est un débat et ça c'est
immédiat en tout cas c'est un débat très
important c'est un débat de société
d'ailleurs on le reverra et peut-être
éventuellement ensemble mais maintenant
merci vincent on se retrouve tout à
l'heure brigitte boucher et tom tran huy
sont face à vous et elles ont des tas de
questions à vous poser sur l'actualité
du parlement et du gouvernement je
ressors olivier marleix que sa joie
elisabeth bande doit consulter les
groupes politiques quand devez vous la
rencontrez demain matin je crois à 9
heures qu'est ce que vous êtes en été au
rendez vous je sais pas j'ai pas eu
connaissance de mer très précise de
l'ordre du jour je pense qu'on va
continuer à parler de la méthode j'ai eu
un premier échange téléphonique avec
elle adore on est en situation très
inédite qui va obliger à une coopération
entre le pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
législatif que l'opération qui est
totalement
inédite c'est notamment inédite pour
pour cet exécutif là qui a
assez peu respectée le parlement ces
cinq dernières années est une bonne
chose dans cette coopération inédite
pour vous oui je sais pas écouter ce
qu'une chose surtout pour un député
d'opposition r2 heureux de pouvoir
d'avoir les moyens de soutenir de
défendre de me battre pour des avancées
pour les français ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai fait des deux précédents mandats
mais avec des gouvernements beaucoup
moins cette écoute là ils vont être
obligés de cette nouvelle méthode est ce
que ça peut passer par un contrat de
coalition un gouvernement d'action comme
a demandé mais là point elisabeth bornes
non c'est très clairement sur la
question de la coalition nous avions
nous avons répondu extrêmement
clairement pour nous il n'en est pas
question une fois encore le projet d'
emmanuel macron n'est pas notre projet
vous avez noté que même si ces propos
lui même invité une condition et sur son
projet ce qui peut tout à fait le
principe des des coéditions dans d
autres démocraties européennes
donc ce projet n'est pas le nom donc
c'est évidemment hors de hors de
question et puis puisque ça je crois que
il faut quand même analyser ce qui s'est
passé dans ce grand chamboulement de la
vie politique à opérer monsieur macron
depuis cinq ans j'aurais l'assemblée
nationale assez atypique mais avec deux
grands groupes aujourd'hui deux parties
la seule volonté aux extrêmes des 89
blessées dans des partis extrémistes
oui quand même plutôt les 89 députés de
la reine où les ou les centres 15
députés la france mise sel est un
sous-produit du maquereau nice-matin
président qui a fracturé le pays et pour
nous il est très important que nous
continuions lui des républicains être
une alternative à offrir une alternative
républicaine dans ce pays on entend ces
opposition constructive ça veut dire
quoi négocier texte par tex partage
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix ça peut
être une position on n'a pas le choix
j'aurais terminé comme d'hab d'un mot
sur la nécessité que les français
comprennent quand même ce qui se joue
depuis depuis cinq ans
très inquiet de savoir ce qui va se
passer et si vous pouvez nous éclairer
sur la façon
sur la nécessité déjà que des
républicains restent une alternative à
part entière reste donc une opposition
même si c'est une opposition qui se veut
une opposition d'intérêt général une
opposition utile moi je suis député de
l'eure et loir je suis voisin d'un
département qui s'appelle département de
l'eure qui n'est pas n'importe quel
département succès le département dont
sont élus monsieur le maire miss de
l'économie et monsieur lecornu deux
grands ministres du gouvernement en
désertant les rangs de la droite ces
gens là ont fait que la droite locale a
peu ou prou disparu et bien quel a été
le résultat des élections législatives
dans le département de l'eure quatre
députés du ratio national a donné samedi
quand vous mettez en garde les
républicains qui seraient tentés d'aller
rejoindre le gouvernement je pense à
jean lautner je pensais que c'était le
moment c'est par exemple c'est à dire
que le jour où les républicains ne sont
plus perçus comme une alternative aux
yeux des aux yeux des français
l'alternative c'est nécessairement le
rassemblement national ce n'est pas ce
que je souhaite pour celles et ceux qui
sont tentés de rejoindre le gouvernement
vous leur dites n'y allez pas
voyez chaque oeil il ya deux éléments de
réponse
le premier c'est que nous avons ce
devoir d'offrir aux français une
alternative
et le deuxième élément si je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes beaucoup plus
utile à 60 à 61 sont deux pour pour
peser sur le cours des choses que dans
des petits débauchages individuels je
comprends parfaitement que des gens
aspirent à entrer au gouvernement
c'était le rêve de damien abad on l'a vu
venir de d'assez loin ce n'est pas une
surprise à mes yeux d'ailleurs voilà
c'est vrai de quelques autres c'est un
traître a du coup non je n'aime pas ce
mot il est un peu aidé un peu un peu
excessif mais enfin oui un peu un
traître la trahison en tout cas de ses
engagements à l'égard de regard de ses
services et de ses des militants qui
font campagne pour vous
vous alerter sur du coup les les
débauchages à ce que voulaient craignais
au sein de votre groupe on les craint
pas un coût tournant du jeu s'est fait
cinq ans que le président de république
à cette obsession de casser une fois
encore les alternative républicaine je
sens une fois encore il faut que les
français qui trouve ça formidable il ya
quelques mois vous avez des gens qui
nous disaient encore mais oui on
pourrait avoir un parti unique c'est
super à la mode c'est vachement bien
parti unique dans quel monde vivons nous
dans quel monde vivons nous faut pas
s'étonner effectivement que le résultat
de tout ça soit que la lnah la seule
alternative se sont départis c'est moi
je ne veux pas de ça pour mon pays je
veux qu'ils dressent une alternative à
droite une alternative républicaine et
donc je leur dis
de ne vous cette confusion cette
confusion elle est malsaine et vous
aurez un film ne seront infiniment plus
utile à 60 puisque là sauf que cette
opposition constructive à vous a pas
tellement réussi à les cinq années qui
viennent de s'écouler
écoutez on va surtout pas été
suffisamment suffisamment lisible
ex-président situation dans un coup dans
un contexte très particulier on ne
reviendra pas avant lundi a voté un
certain nombre de réformes la réforme de
la sncf la réforme de l'assurance
chômage beaucoup on a cherché oui on a
cherché ce qu'on pouvait voter
d'ailleurs on a déjà essayé de faire de
faire oeuvre utile et d'accompagner le
mouvement réformateur qui avait avait
cité il ya eu trois réformes en tout et
pour tout la réforme du chômage dans les
femmes de la sncf il ya un petit bout de
réforme du marché du travail
du coup qu'est ce que vous allez faire
oui sur six prochaines années est-ce que
vous on va faire des dessins faire notre
travail d'un parti politique on va pas
s'enfermer dans une danse d'une méthode
lorsque c'est trop tôt puisque on est
tous on découvre une situation inédite
d'oran la possibilité soit d'approuver
un texte de le voter si nous si nous
convient si le gouvernement a entendu
suffisamment ce que nous souhaitions
dans la possibilité de s'abstenir avec
le risque pour le gouvernement qui ne
passent pas la possibilité aussi de dire
au gouvernement non ça on n'en veut pas
on ne prendra pas il faudra pas compter
sur nous et puis on aura une autre
possibilité aussi qui est qui qui est
intéressante c'est de dire au
gouvernement va écouter ok vous
absolument qu'on avance sur cette
réforme on est prêt à le faire mais on
vous demande à l'ordre du jour de
prendre tel autre texte que par exemple
des jeux ratés par par la majorité
sénatoriale
et donnant-donnant vous dit on fera
n'utilisera les moyens de dispositions
pour faire avancer les idées que les
français nous ont demandé de porter
voilà je suis macron a été extrêmement
timide en matière de contrôle des flux
migratoires c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il ya aucune volonté en matière de
politique pénale on est resté sur les
loi taubira ces cinq dernières années
avec en matière de retraite avec
monsieur dupont moretti en matière de
retraite l'on a mis un projet sur la sur
la table maintenant il appartient je
suis pour le respect des partenaires
sociaux des fins des corps
intermédiaires en général du parlement
et en matière de retraite n'oubliez pas
que ce soit dit ce sont les partenaires
sociaux qui qui négocient que même les
cotisations sociales
il faut déjà que
deux voies d'une discussion demain vous
voyez dans quel isabelle borne va
certainement vous poser la question est
ce que vous allez voter la confiance la
semaine prochaine à l'issue du discours
de politique générale mardi prochain
priori le 5 juillet je lui poserai déjà
la question de savoir s'ils me posent
des questions et c'est la pause on
répondra à la question de confiance
quand elle nous sera posée c'est de la
fausse page pas vous pas vous répondre à
cette question on imposera vous dit pas
d'emblée on va voter contre car nous
sommes l'opposition ah si c'est pour
faire tomber immédiatement le
gouvernement ça paraît pas totalement
utiles une fois encore moi je fais
partie de ceux qui ont voté sans état
d'âme contre la confiance à tous les
goûts des manuels macron depuis le début
du précédent quinquennat
cela dit on n'y avait pas de risque
sur votre compte la confiance ça ferait
trop mais le gouvernement pourrait faire
des dons aux associations tension alors
comment on n'a pas eu ce débat et on
l'aura ci s'il ya lieu voilà papa mois
dans une carte postale ce qu'on va faire
de prendre ses responsabilités d'abord
et s'il n'y avait pas de vote de
confiance c'est une possibilité elle
n'est pas obligée de demander la
confiance à l'issue de son discours de
politique générale est ce que vous
feriez une motion de censure on entend
la france un souterrain du canal est une
opposition responsable
très sincèrement censurer un
gouvernement qui vient d'être nommé
avant même qu'on connaisse sa feuille de
route ça me paraîtrait pas extrêmement
responsable donc ça c'est non là je
pense pouvoir vous répondre évidemment
c'est la france un soumise à un concours
mais a priori je pense que cette
démarche n'aurait pas grand sens vous
avez entendu certainement bruno le maire
ce matin qui dit que la côte d'alerté
est atteinte en matière de finances
publiques est ce que ça vous rassure
à écouter week ont atterri sans fin je
veux bien enfin je suis très sincèrement
assez consterné que dans ceux dans ce
pays dans notre pays depuis cinq ans
chaque personne à part les républicains
absolument personne n'ait parlé de ce
sujet on s'est endettée allègrement bien
avant l'heure
philippin quand même pardon de la nette
s'était en effet déjà un héritage je
dois filer voulait dire oui c'est un
fait a commencé ce d'affilée je pense
que le meilleur budget de monsieur
macron des gouvernants de monsieur mc
ren est un peu doit être doit être
pire que le meilleur budget de monsieur
une mesure de plus voir la charente
d'urgence est ce que vous les vôtres et
non pardon j'ai en tout cas en tout cas
cette crise oui on
arrive effectivement suis sur le poids
de chasse point d'achat je pense
sincèrement qu'il ya un moyen que nous
soyons le plus nombreux possible au sein
de l'assemblée nationale à nous
retrouver je dirais madame bornes demain
quels sont les
philosophies de mai des mesures que l'on
attend notamment qu'on soit
particulièrement attentifs à la france
qui travaille aux gens qui on a roulé
pour pour aller pour à leur travail et
ce particulièrement insoutenable
aujourd'hui pour des gens qui
travaillent question des salaires au
niveau du smic
on a
on va avoir une aura discussion là
dessus sur la mesure la plus appropriée
la plus ils devaient ça coûte cher à
votre mesure d'un milliard d'abord cela
oui
soucieux des deniers publics alors
ça dépend comment on compte
comment compter comme on arrivait à dix
mille hommes en compte mais ça dépend
sur les sodas taxe sur la taxe de
bordeaux peut supprimer la uniquement la
tva sur l'athéisme pe comme une tache
sur la tâche ensuite ça c'est à peu près
4 milliards d'euros ensuite on peut
décider d'aller un peu plus loin de se
baisser aussi la tei cpe voilà en fait
on fait absolument ce qu'on veut en la
matière au chiffre de l'effort comme
ainsi le défunt comme aujourd'hui que
l'objectif de 50 le litre donc on est
bien sûr diminue tous à tous oui ça
dépend comment compte certains vous
diront que ça dépend du
prix du baril en tout cas oui on veut
une mesure assez massive sur la france
qui travaille donc la croûte ya aussi la
question peut-être aussi la question de
la cg et notre originalité probablement
par rapport à tous les deux groupes
d'opposition c'est évidemment le
financement de ces mesures
vous proposez quoi ce serait très
choquée que le gouvernement ne propose
pas de mesures de finances mais vous
vous proposez aussi des mesures puisque
votre
de financement moi je pense qu'il ya
deux pistes qu'on a mis aussi sur la
table pendant la campagne présidentielle
initiatives de lutte contre la fraude
sociale la cour des comptes et même
estime qu' à plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros de fraude sociale on
apprécie d une commission d enquête sur
ce sujet là on a tous les chiffres on a
des mesures très précises à proposer
comme la carte vitale biométrique par
exemple comme demandé aux uns ou aux
gens qui touchent leur retraite à
l'étranger d'aller se manifester une
fois par an au consulat c'est que ce que
font tous les pays d'europe j'ai déjà
rencontré dans le village pendant ma
campagne petit village j'avais des
allemands qui venait pointer une fois
par an et obtenir un certificat sur
lesquels ils étaient encore en vie et
que la france qui versent des
à l'étranger sans se poser la moindre
question tu ça et à bord et pardon et
plaisirs de la fraude fiscale notamment
tu sais ces folies de près de transfert
que des français ont découvert avec
lésions de la sphère mckinsey ces
pratiques ou pour connaît aussi à
travers
travers de general electric toutes ces
affaires sont absolument insupportable
pour les français c'est une concurrence
injuste déloyale pour nos entreprises
donc il faut aussi que le gouvernement
remette de l'ordre des arts est
d'autoriser ce genre de pratiques
le premier texte qui va arriver un texte
a minima pour prolonger certaines
dispositions de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est ce que vous allez le voter
alors ce n'est absolument pas ce texte
on ne connaît rien et on n'a aucune
donnée encore de la part du gouvernement
sur les mesures
je suis sur la situation épidémiologique
vous voyez que c'est en train pour la
préservation des données c'est ça que la
prolongation du pad sanitaires je joue
je vous laisse regarder ce qu'on était
des votes des républicains sur ce final
et donc j'invite le gouvernement a
évidemment bien réfléchir là encore aux
mesures qui le proposera et vous allez
demander que votre groupe est une une
petite commune à une pulsion plus
parvenir à terme à la dernière voir on a
pratiqué la liberté de vote sur ces
sujets dans chaque à chaque fois je
[Musique]
j'admets parfaitement la liberté de vote
sur des sujets et le sujet de ce type au
sein du groupe voilà en tout cas on
s'engagera pas de l'hégire sur ces
mesures qui étaient des mesures
privatives de liberté extrêmement
extrêmement grave la berbère mais très
brièvement parce qu'on attend il est
tombé ou par brigitte bourguignon qui
recommande de porter le masque dans les
transports est ce que pour vous il faut
le rendre à nouveau obligatoire
aujourd'hui dit on a aucune donnée de la
part du gouvernement donc moi j'attends
d'avoir des mesures des données du
gouvernement lula habitué quand même à
des choses assez étonnante je me
souviens avoir auditionné mois de
décembre monsieur enfin le professeur
delfraissy qui nous expliquait que avec
au micro les choses allaient se calmer
c'est le moment au gouvernement d'en
profiter pour un tour de vis avec le
pass vaccinale donc je suis assez
méfiant sur sur la façon dont le
gouvernement prépare ces mesures elle va
déjà pas être facile pour ce premier
tech merci beaucoup brigitte et âme dans
un instant extraire va nous rejoindre
petite question comment vous allez
exister dans un hémicycle plein de bruit
de fureur avec un débat qui tentera
d'être monopolisée par la france est
soumise aux
députés qui ont fuit depuis cinq ans
parfois depuis dix ans ont beaucoup
travaillé non non pas beaucoup intéressé
parfois vous vos confrères parce que il
y avait cette fascination pour le mot
sonne
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser un peu plus à ce qu' il ya
des sujets sur lesquels on a été seul
pendant pendant des années la question
de la souveraineté industrielle c'est
nous qui l'avons posée sur la table
faisait rigoler la macro nylon ils ont
arrêté de ré la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est un sujet qui faisait rigoler tout
le monde on a été les seuls à ce que
vous me répondez c'est nous on sera sur
des sujets de fond d'ailleurs on dit
dans le fond il est marc l'ex c'est un
homme qui fait du fonds eh bien on verra
c'est par notre travail et pas par des
mises en scène ou d'écouteurs dans
l'hémicycle on a bien compris ce très
bon soir
olivier marleix qui ont ce noël demain
dans le figaro
deux tribunes sont publiés deux tribunes
la première elle est signée de votre
plume avec votre collègue bruno
retailleau et vous dites ce que vous
pensez de la situation qu'il est hors de
question de pactiser avec le
gouvernement en place et la majorité en
place et puis une autre tribune qui est
signé par christian estrosi et une
soixantaine d'élus de beaucoup de maires
tous quasiment viennent de la droite
est ce que il y aurait pas en france de
droite irréconciliables
pour paraphraser monsieur valls sur la
gauche
n'avait pas échappé la france aux
grandeurs
coûté 60 sur sur 600 mille élus locaux
voilà non je ne suis resté charitable
quand même en ce début de ce début de
session
le gouvernement a beaucoup fait dépenser
beaucoup d'énergie pour pour appâter des
locaux c'est assez facile quand vous
êtes au pouvoir essayé d'appâter des
gens d'où vous faire des amis
donc il a trouvé des gens sensibles
sensible à sa cause
voilà je pense que ce n'est pas cette
position est un objet non pas seul à
seul de rappeler en moins néanmoins vous
avez un homme qui est pas tendre avec le
gouvernement qui a la dent très dure qui
s'appelle jean-françois copé maire de
meaux et qui dit ne pas faire une
coalition avec le gouvernement avec la
majorité actuelle c'est tombé dans un
piège démoniaque dit il ce matin sur
france inter et et jean françois copé il
peut pas être suspecté de je dirais de
devoir alors peut-être si tu ne vois tu
vois quand même aujourd'hui extrêmement
singulière pour ne pas dire solitaire
dans notre famille politique il était le
seul au bureau politique à tenir deux
républicain à tenir 7,7 cette ligne là
répète régulièrement je pense qu'il
répétera jusqu'à ce que pourquoi son cv
soit sont reçues sur la table du
jeu je sais pas mais ce n'est pas notre
ligne est notre notre fois encore je
pense qu'on a une vraie divergence des
analyses dont moi je me suis je
l'analyse que font aujourd'hui la
totalité
des députés les républicains ou des ou
des sénateurs c'est que on ne peut pas
laisser le pays dans un face à face
entre cette espèce de parti à parti
unique et les extrêmes vous êtes unis la
seule on est de la tunisie sur cette
ligne ça a été dit très clairement
bureau politique des républicains c'est
la position de nos de nos deux groupes
parlementaires on a fait qu à lagnieu là
dessus on sera une opposition
responsable
on saura on sera travaillé pour le bien
du pays arracher des avancées pour les
français puissent constituer pour les
arracher mais pas de confusion ce sera
plus là où vous êtes cette caisse qui
est intéressant à la tribune que vous
publiez encore une fois si vous faites
votre mea culpa aussi vous dit la droite
a trop souvent brouillé sa ligne est-ce
que là et bien vous estimez que vous
avez une ligne qui est clair pour les
français alors que les français
demandent justement le vote des français
peut être interprété comme ça à ce que
et bien les gens arrivent à gouverner
ensemble je crois qu'une une question de
fond une question de méthode d'accord
sur la question de fond
il faut être extrêmement clair notre
projet n'est pas celui d'emmanuel macron
une fois encore si on reprend les
principaux chapitres de sa politique
devant le l'endettement colossal du pays
3000 milliards de bannières de dette la
seule hausse des taux d'intérêt le petit
début celle la banque centrale
européenne a arrêté il ya un mois et
demi de racheter la dette française
qu'est ce qui se passe il faut aller sur
les marchés financiers des marchés
financiers il regarde la situation de
chaque pays
première levée d'emprunt la france
emprunte à 2.4 mon sens de taux
d'intérêt les allemands à 1% 2,4 ça veut
dire quoi pour la france ça veut dire 84
milliards de charges de la dette
supplémentaire 84 milliards c'est plus
que le produit d'impôt sur le revenu
mais moi je suis français responsable la
droite est responsable aussi le but 74e
budget cas et les cas une des bucs été
volés à l' équilibre le dernier
président à eux oui d'accord le dernier
puis on oublie que de droite qui a
gouverné s'appelait nicolas sarkozy ya
une dette terry labo il a beaucoup donné
il a beaucoup de défauts mais il a
cherché à réduire la dépense publique à
plusieurs reprises pendant son
quinquennat le seulement c'est le seul
président de la république depuis
malades qui étaient peut-être maladroite
effectivement le nom
bien sûr mais on assume hectares mais
c'est le seul présent d'appui si votre
état date est formidable allons-y mais
vous verrez quand on empruntera à 5%
comment fait on empruntera à 6% comme
comme les écoles et les allemands vous
verrez on sera obligé de faire des lois
de finances rectificatives tous les
quinze auto portant sur le fond pour
revenir à votre question on n'est pas du
tout sur la même ligne politique que
monsieur macron après les français nous
envoyer à tous aux prisons de la
république et aux familles politiques
représentés la solitaire un message
coopérer dans notre intérêt on vous
demande de ne pas vous chamailler on
vous demande tous essayé de travailler
ensemble et ça ne peut pas faire ça
c'est la méthode c'est on va faire voilà
alors à l'intérieur d'eux il ya une
autre tribune qui est paru il ya pas
très longtemps de jeunes élus de votre
famille politique parce qu'elle est là
la fracture c'est un peu comme pour la
france les feux de la fracture est aussi
générationnel et ces jeunes élus qu'on
connaît qui sont monsieur pradier
monsieur dumont et quelques autres
disent on en a assez ils disent des noms
d'ailleurs ils donnent des noms dans là
c'est de voir à la télé lyon des gens
qui nous représente et nous on veut que
ça change alors ici de monsieur
hortefeux ici peña mme dati site madame
morano il ne vous cite pas parce que
vous devez l'excitation et qu'est-ce que
comment vous allez et comment vous allez
gérer ça vous observe que la jeunesse
passe mais que son inspiration
au renouvellement se renouvelle à peu
près à toutes et à toutes les
générations
voilà ce soyons pas caricaturaux
je pense que tu mens il ya peut-être
parce que c'est pas une question d'âge
du tout c'est une question de
représentativité et parfois qui est qui
et qui est posée dans une opacité ils
tiennent pour responsables de la
dégradation de l'état de la droite
wild en mai il ya des gens dans la rue
cité d'autres tout à l'heure il ya des
gens qui s'expriment souvent qu'ils
n'ont plus beaucoup forcément de raison
de raison de s'exprimer quand on réunit
les comités stratégiques et qu'on voit
arriver certaines personnes qui dans qui
n'ont plus de 2 de représentativité très
fortes vagues rarement je partage pas le
partager leurs sentiments voilà
un vrai quand même non aujourd'hui les
portes qu'on entend le plus sur les
plateaux c'était leur expression les
jantes hors jeu aurait remis
au numéro 2 de républicains il a eu des
responsabilités très important
pour le coup je peux attaquer attaquer
des personnes
mais il ya en tout cas il y aura des
échéances bientôt n'être alors justement
retient alors justement ce qu'ils ont
vraiment parlé quel est le les
républicains vont se donner un président
de chez jacob a décidé de remettre son
mandat rabat de remettre son mandat de
quitter la présidence qui est votre
candidat favori qui vous verriez pour
faire justement la synthèse et dirigé ce
parti je sais je sais pas pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de pas de candidat un nom
qui circule beaucoup n'y a pas de
candidat déclaré oui mais pas
d'explosion de
lancer un appel à candidatures moi
sincèrement mais j'aspire à ce que tout
le monde sont en deuil et j'ai eu cette
discussion avec l'inde est encore temps
de la jeune génération pense que dans
l'état où on est évidemment c'est très
bien qu'ils aient un peu de la zac de la
vie en interne mais sa mention pouvait s
s'épargner le ridicule d'élections
d'élections internes qui qui qui
passionne pas les foules avec 50
candidats vous savez qu'elle est là la
rumeur qui serait pas en ville c'est que
monsieur wauquiez bas ça le titille
beaucoup mais qui voudrait patienter
jusqu'aux européennes et que d'ici là eh
bien ça serait monsieur barnier qui
présiderait le parti c'est quelque chose
qui change en le coûteux justice j'aurai
je connais pas ce rumeurs beaucoup
d'autres dotations il faudra passer par
une élection on passe à une élection
c'est sûr évidemment le jeu que le seul
qui plaide pour une autre solution enfin
je sais pas voilà non mais voilà il y
aura d'ailleurs à une élection
maintenant dire à dire à une élection
c'est ce que veulent nos statuts il n'y
a pas de raison de ne pas faire c'est
dur à cette élection voilà et puis je
mens j'aimerais qu'on ne perde pas trop
de temps
j'aimerais que voilà que j'ai rapidement
on est on est on est un chef
et court chrono pas de spectacle de
divisions édicules qu'est ce que vous
pensez d'ailleurs est ce que monsieur sa
cote est d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'il
est toujours un jour donc il
n'est pas très longtemps il a rappelé
qu'il était jour de cotisation derrière
questions sur monsieur abad il ya une
plainte qu'il dépose et encore pour
violences sexuelles contre lui est ce
que vous estimez que
eh bien il doit démissionner du
gouvernement je pense vraiment que c'est
au président de la république et à la
première ministre qui ont fait des
questions sur les violences sexuelles et
c'est une priorité de prendre leurs
responsabilités voilà je veux pas
pourquoi je vais à câbler personne
mais sa responsabilité c'est eux qui
nomme c'est pas moi merci beaucoup a eu
beaucoup merci beaucoup ça fait dix ans
vous êtes député olivier marc l'ex
vous êtes à qui on entend sur la
situation de la france sur un certain
égard et à 16 sur certains aspects c'est
très clair sur la capacité ou pas de
trouver les voies et moyens de gouverner
vous êtes optimiste quand même vous
dites là on est dans une nasse on est
dans de l'inédit et je ne sais pas du
tout où on va alors si je crois que
c'était quand même un défi d'abord pour
quel ancien président de la république
puisque c'est oui
du président
c'est vraiment lui qui a cette
responsabilité il est de le gardien
dominant il a été rayé du prêt d'un
public il a sollicité une majorité
auprès des français qui nous a souhaité
de lui donner c'est à lui d'en tirer des
tirs et les conclusions et de créer les
conditions de 2,2 ce dialogue voilà et
donc ça va demander un peu de plasticité
du côté de son ego on savait qu'il avait
une certaine plasticité sur le plan
idéologique
joël était contre nucléaire un jour il
était pour le sujet est assez plastique
falloir maintenant que son une montre
que son ego peut aussi s'adapter et que
effectivement une et plus jupiter il
doit plus être dans cette présidence là
le souhait des français il faut encore
c'est qu'il soit obligé de collaborer
avec le débat est lancé finalement la
balle est très clairement dit olivier
molex dans le camp du président de la
république va t'il savoir changer
bonsoir à vous vous êtes président du
groupe euler hermes je résume au sénat
et merci d'être là pour débattre
directement et interpeller olivier marc
l'ex très bien voir consolider ma relève
d'abord je vous félicite pour l'élection
votre groupe vient de vous et lui hier
je vous ai écouté tout à l'heure j'ai lu
la tribune que vous avez signé
vous définissez comme un anti ma
chronique pragmatique et vous ne voulez
pas servir de l'équipe du gouvernement
on va essayer de passer aux travaux
pratiques mais je vous ai écoutés depuis
le début de l'émission débute vous
trouvez plutôt modérée ensuite sans
nuance et ensuite un peu caricatural je
vous le dis comme tels parce que vous
avez oublié de parler du chômage j'avais
oublié de parler de la façon dont est
traitée locaux vides vous avez oublié de
parler d'apprentissage république et de
parler des baisses d'impôts tout ce
qu'ils sont des succès du gouvernement
que vous avez totalement occulté je
donne comme tel mais je vous le redis
alors maintenant d'abord ce qui me fait
un peu sourire c'est quand vous déclarez
que vous êtes heureux de voir que le
pouvoir revient au parlement pour un
gaulliste un petit peu se fixe ça m'a
surpris un petit peu quand je vais
pouvoir me dire ça je dis le pouvoir
revient au parlement dans l'esprit des
gaullistes s'était pas vraiment ce qui
était à l'origine de la vème république
mais question je voudrais vous poser
c'est que c'est clair il ya des grands
défis devant nous il ya des difficultés
il ya les dangers cela ne s'est pas
perdre tant pas perdre temps et définir
clairement la position qui sera la vôtre
et compte tenu des défis d'ailleurs je
lui aussi qu' il ya un sondage
contrairement ce que vous avez pu dire
75 % de vos électeurs disent qu'il faut
vous rapprocher du gouvernement et du
sondage là cet après midi alors ma
poésie ma question est la suivante est
ce que vous allez vous protéger en
raison de l'opposition et dans le
blocage ou bien ce que vous allez
participer aux solutions aux problèmes
qui nous sont posées la réponse est
évidemment la
seconde journée on est là pour cette pac
blocage n'y participera pas
et donc on pour chercher des civilités
d'avancé de trouver des solutions aux
problèmes qui se posent au pays
je reviens quand même un point peut
provoquer sur eux sur le bouddhisme
ludique de leur équilibre a chez les
français c'est les français qui l'ont
voulu quand on fait le choix de ne pas
donner cette majorité absolue c'est un
choix assez inédit un camouflet qu'un un
peu inédit pour le prénom d'un public il
y en a d'autres qui ont connu ça avec
des franchement bien pire avec des avec
des cohabitations l'un n'est pas
exactement ce stade là on est on est
dans un entre deux il faut que le
président de la république apprennent à
parler avec tout le monde il faut quand
même le général de gaulle l'a fait il le
fait d'aider juin 40 à londres il a
cherché le contact tous les autres il
l'a fait et après 158 pour pour revenir
donc ça doit être ça dope est impossible
nous on assumera aussi cette
responsabilité c'est pour ça que j'ai
demandé par exemple madame madame bornes
c'est pas un secret je peux révéler j'ai
demandé à ce qu'on puisse avoir un peu
de lisibilité sur sur les projets du
gouvernement
allait à l'échelle d'une session pour
pouvoir leur dire ben écoute et oui sur
ce texte offre d'achat des français
évidemment si une priorité majeure pour
tout le monde donc là dessus il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver les moyens d'un
accord
je les ai alerté sur le fait que par
exemple par en revanche sur edf ça
risque d'être plus compliqué si le
projet consistait à nous ressortir le
projet recul de démembrement d'edf sur
lesquels irish que pour le coup d'avoir
toutes les oppositions contre donc voilà
il ya ce travail il ya ce travail à
faire je pense qu'il est important que
le gouvernement nous donne un petit peu
de un peu de moyens d'anticiper et puis
on dira aussi ce qui nous va ce qui ne
va pas et on dira à la case des chances
qui manque ce sur quoi on souhaite que
le gouvernement avance la visibilité a
fait mais vous dites vous n'adhérez pas
au projet d' emmanuel macron dont vous
vous dites qu'il est versatile à
géométrie variable par pendant ces
termes vous êtes un ancien socialiste
c'est
moi je suis pas un ancien socialiste
mais moi je ne regrette pas de m'être
ancien social et jeudi comme telle celle
été et j'ai toujours le coeur à gauche
on va sur et vous non ce que je voudrais
vous qu'on vous dit vous n'adhérez pas
au projet des manuels macron kilti le
projet d'ailleurs il n'a pas demandé à
ce que revienne sur son projet
intégralement il a dit sur le cadre de
mon projet le cadre ce projet c'est quoi
si aujourd'hui la valeur travail vous y
tenez comme moi c'est la sécurité c'est
la sécurité mais comme moi c'est
l'environnement c'est l'éducation et
c'est la santé c'est sur ce cadre là et
non pas sur le projet auquel 2005 alors
maintenant le projet dénoncent pas les
mots tuent ceux des mauges une brochette
de mola par le justice sécurité que vous
repensé non mais il faudra d'abord sur l
oubli le dis à tout à l'heure quel est
le gouvernement qui a augmenté deux fois
de suite de 15 % le budget de la justice
quel est le gouvernement qui au besoin
non mais faut pas se laisser trop
d'huile 500 magistrats ils ont été créés
ils ont titré quand je vais te crées
fier c'était beaucoup des places de
prison que vous avez contre du
kilométrage et de dire la même chose
pour la même temps les bailleurs ne ment
pas le gouvernement
quel est le gouvernement qui a mis
autant dans le secteur de la santé pour
essayer de remettre putallaz niveau
qu'est ce qu'une amie autant tout à
l'heure vous disiez ya pas de
gynécologues il n'y a pas de médecin bon
qu'est ce qui a mis en place le numerus
clausus c'est un problème
c'est pas des mots vous avez une
décision qui a été prise par un premier
ministre que vous avez soutenu alors
maintenant quand vous dites le projet d'
emmanuel macron qui est il bien suprême
le projet sur le numerus clausus
l'université les autorités n'y aura pas
plus de médecins regardez il y en a déjà
plus en deuxième année beaucoup plus
qu'ils avaient ya trois ans le projet
d'emmanuel maintenant il est le suivant
faire du progrès social par les progrès
social sans augmenter les impôts et sans
augmenter la question de la dette via
des comités un peu manichéen comme si
toute la dette de la france vous ne
l'avez accumulé autant d' emmanuel
macron ce que je voudrais vous dire à ce
sujet c'est quand même que quand on a
fait de la dette et que le gouvernement
quel était le gouvernement qui avait
ramené le déficit en dessous des 3% de
pib c'est bien ce gouvernement qu'il
avait fait ensuite pourquoi ça a dérapé
et vous le savez très bien pourquoi ça a
dérapé c'est à cause de la crise qu
vides et alors quand on a fait de la
dette à ce moment là le quoi qu'il en
coûte est ce que vous étiez contre ce
qu'il fallait pas aider les entreprises
et ce qu'il fallait pas payer les
salariés la réponse
sur ce sujet là non mais sur ce sujet
vous oubliez quand même vous fait le
procès de la dette comme si toute la
dette globale était dû à emmanuel macron
et les duels et ses soeurs de nommer
trois mille milliards de mai le seul
gouvernement qui avait ramené le déficit
en dessous de 3% si celui là alors
olivier marais les 3% c'est un calcul
qui tient compte de 6-5 faudra sans
doute tous effectivement sur ganis en
fonction de la croissance que vous
pouvez afficher cette année là la
réalité se connaît quasiment pas eu un
budget voté avec un déficit de moins de
100 milliards j'assure dans les pires
déficits que la france a connu c'est
y compris des années avant que vides
françois hollande fait preuve a fait
preuve de rigueur budgétaire à côté des
benêts macron c'est comme ça la réalité
de ce pays la première l'hôtel et
collective il est mais ça bouge à la
première loi de finances combien
d'emplois combien d'emplois publics ont
été supprimés 1400 emploie 1400 emplois
sur 2 millions et demi d'emplois dans le
périmètre de l'état lesquelles je suis
prêt mais là j'aimerais bien vous me
disiez faut les supprimer à l'hôpital à
l'efa l'école de faire un tour dans les
centrales à l'école les vols aller faire
un tour dans les administrations
centrales monsieur patriat c'est le
gouvernement leur effet c'est absolument
aberrant mais nicolas sarkozy l'a fait
lui et le coche à la pallice oui
effectivement politique de recul avec le
recul peut-être que d'hergé pépé était
un peu trop un peu trop brutale et
peut-être notamment qui est une erreur
de méthode moi je concède une erreur de
méthode qui était de demander aux
administrations centrales de faire ça
aide qu'elle se sont protégés et elles
ont supprimé les services publics en
bout de chaîne ce qui était une ce qui
était une faute et une erreur mais au
moins on a essayé de faire quelque chose
qui n'a pas été le cas ces cinq
dernières années et je pense que nous
aurons une situation malheureusement
très grave c'est facile à vrai dire
c'est l'argent quand c'est uniquement à
crédit jamais fait connaître à la vie
extrêmement difficiles et il ne pas
payer les salariés il doit aider les
entreprises en monsieur pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a une reprise aussi fort
globalement parce qu'on a dépensé de
l'argent à bon escient et au bon moment
une reprise de subventionner la
croissance
après je ne critique qu'est-ce qui se
passe
c'est là qu'elle a tiré d'aile de mixer
la grange à une toute petite partie date
ses 125 milliards ces 125 milliards
seulement suis allé sur les 700 milles
sur les plus de 700 milliards qui ont
été le théâtre cumulé pendant ce mandat
à voir la crise que vit de ça la réalité
vous avez la réponse à votre sur la
dette je crois que bruno le maire l'a
redit ce matin il s'y est engagé la
politique va mener ce gouvernement si
j'espère qu'il y aura des soutiens de
l'opposition ce sera effectivement de
stopper la dette de la réduire de la
réduire tu te continuer à ne pas
augmenter les impôts c'est déjà beaucoup
alors peut-être une autre question
j'aimerais vous poser c j'ai pas bien
compris votre contradictions je le dis
souvent sans animosité d'un côté vous
dites il faut baisser la tva il faut
baisser la tpe font baisser la cdg mais
si vous faites cela aujourd'hui comment
vous allez faire pour faire plus de
moyens pour l'hôpital plus pour les cols
plus pour les personnages et plus pour
l'autonomie comment vous allez faire
c'est bien que si on réduit ça alors
vous avez dit on va trouver des
économies à côte et la fraude fiscales
coûtaient quel est le gouvernement qui a
le plus aujourd'hui fait de prélèvements
soit disant qu'il faut donc il faut le
fisc c'est ce gouvernement là tous les
enfants ont quitté 20 milliards l'an
dernier encore chaque année on a fait
plus que personne n'avait fait avant
alors toujours vous allez vous allez
j'ai compris soutenir ce qui est
dépenses ce qui est des dépenses et puis
quand il s'agira de faire des efforts
est ce que vous serez là on a fait ce
que vous serez là on a on a
régulièrement fait des propositions en
matière de 2,2 de réduction de la
dépense publique évidemment c
on n'a jamais été entendue depuis cinq
ans sur sur ces sujets là
où fallait-il en faire moi ça j'aime
bien parce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure dans les administrations
centrales l'accord bon mais c'est pas
dégeu j'ai eu la curiosité de demander
combien dans ce pays il y avait de très
hauts fonctionnaires des gens qui sont
payés sur des niveaux de hors échelle
c'est très technique pardon de cesser
des gens qui ont des niveaux de
rémunérations les plus élevées dans
notre retour dans la hotte
mais si c'est des gens qui sont qui
donne environ à partir de au moins 5000
euros au moins 5000 euros par mois dans
la dhr dans la haute administration
on en a plus de 70000 puis 70 milles
j'ai eu la curiosité de savoir combien
n'avait avant la décentralisation vous
avez été président de région qu'est-ce
que ça devait être à voir
décentralisation bien avant
décentralisation il y en avait 25 mille
da depuis la décentralisation
on a multiplié quasiment par trois le
nombre de très hauts fonctionnaires dans
ce pays on a une administration et
paralyser de la vidéo des toits risque
qui n'est pas dans le service qui n'est
pas dans le service public je pense
qu'il ya un immense travail à faire de
ce côté là avec derrière des moyens de
fonctionnement très très très important
il faut c'est poursuivre ça m'intéresse
aux fonctionnaires payés à partir de
5000 euros pourtant ce sont des salaires
trop important vous dites car leurs
fonctionnaires je dis qu'il ya trop de
hauts fonctionnaires très bien pu très
très bien payé il ya une sud très haute
administration qui est aujourd'hui
surabondante dans ce pays je pense que
deuxième
mission en paix tant est qu'ils sont
honnêtes bac s qu'ils font pour
s'occuper il fonde la norme voilà donc
ce pays crève sous l'énorme fait pas
recette je pense que le président
l'ancien président de région que vous
êtes voit un peu de quoi je veux parler
et donc on a aujourd'hui des services de
l'état qui font de la norme
niveau national ce qui explique que
cette explosion normative ça permet de
réduire la tête supprimer 1 % par an
faites le calcul c'est des gens qui vous
coûte t moyens de fonctionnement qui
vous coûte en moyenne 5000 euros c'est
le début de l'échelle ça va beaucoup
plus haut c'est des gens qui vous coûte
en moyenne 150 millions je
vous en supprimer 10% par an fait un
milliard d'euros d'économies chaque
année c'est intéressant
cent mille emplois il a fait comme tel
si aperçu ici a perçu qu'en fin de
compte les emplois pour voudrait
supprimer immédiatement c'est pas aussi
simple que ça ces gens là aujourd'hui
travaillent pour la nation font
travailler la nation par ailleurs
prennent les décisions c'est ça c'est
les solutions faciles c'est comme quand
les communistes comme quoi les
communistes il faut prendre l'argent là
où
georges marchais divers chiffres autre
ère les marchés a atteint des chiffres
très précis
aujourd'hui on crève sur la norme mais
c'est chez vidal pourquoi ne l'avait pas
bouffer de temps vous étiez au pouvoir
si c'est vrai on a fait
ça vous avez pas si vous n'avez pas
supprimer de postes de hauts
fonctionnaires
en 2007 citez moi j'ai fait bien boc
nous au moins on a fait on a essayé
quelque chose effectivement tu n'étais
pas forcément habile mais on a essayé
quelque chose je suis observe c'est
depuis dix ans on n'a rien essayé en
matière jour monsieur malek cette année
s'est positionné il nous faut sujet
atelier lequel on devrait voir
sur le cas de report sur tout mais moi
je pense que dans ce pays il faut
on ne coupera pas c'est pas crédible de
le dire le robinet de la redistribution
du jour au lendemain en supprimant les
de toutes les toutes les allocations et
ça je pense par contre il ya une idée
qui est importante c'est d'activer au
maximum la dépense dépenses sociales de
la rendre plus utile plus pertinente
j'ai fait une proposition dans le projet
des républicains qui a été reprise par
emmanuel macron c'est 15 heures
demandées aux allocataires du rsa de
soin de suivre une formation soit de
reprendre de participer à hauteur de 15
heures 15 heures pourquoi c'est une
règle de trois par rapport au smic a été
reprise dans le programme annuel mac
exactement cette voie là et bonjour suis
vraiment très demandé
à ces gens de participer par dano à la
vie dont n'osais pas dans nos maisons
retraite ou en manque cruellement de
personnel je suis d'accord avec du mal à
augmenter la dépense sociale ou pourra
pas augmenter les prix de journée pour
les pour les payer par les familles donc
il faut trouver des ressources
supplémentaires pourquoi ne pas demander
aux gens s'ils savaient qu'à terre du
rsa qu'on aurait évidemment mis en
situation préparer et sert à former un
minimum de participer bas à distribuer
des petits déjeuners des gens et des
quais les points sur lesquels on peut se
retrouver à prendre leurs repas et pour
moi c'est dire si les différences et je
regrette qu'ils modèlent mac ronde n'est
pas repris cette dimension-là du projet
pour moi c'est une question de dignité
pour tous parce que je pense qu un pays
où chacun d'eux ne participe pas à la
société un pays où l'état renoncerait à
demander à des français de participer à
la société dit prendre leurs passes
cessé de nous c'est une atteinte forte à
la cohésion nationale chacun chacun est
nécessaire
et donc voilà une idée sur l
malheureusement prennent la république
comme la gauche son aile gauche à un peu
grenier sur cette idée là l'abandonner
aussitôt non je pense que ce
papa triant il a abandonné
je pense qu'elle est dans le projet dans
le cadre du projet j'espère qu'elle sera
mis en oeuvre je dois quand même posé
une question peut
on en a un petit peu moins
le fait de mettre les gens formations
rsa a fait hurler lannux d'accord avec
vous semblez d'accord en forme assure
une grande qualité et je le regrette
bien entendu non mais l'objectif c'est
de les mettre en formation pour aller
vers l'emploi et quand on a fait par
exemple voulait oublier aussi pour 10
milliards un plan un jeune une solution
unique au banjo nous travaille beaucoup
parce qu'aujourd'hui le chômage des
jeunes j'habite un territoire où
maintenant l'eau et au plein emploi
parce que les jeunes ont été pris dans
un jeune une solution c'est que si je
vous ai posé une question m vous vous
dites aujourd'hui c'est pas notre
programme c'est pas notre projet j'ai
entendu madame pécresse pendant la
campagne tous les jours on arrive à elle
seule se lamentait de dire écoutez c'est
du copié-collé mâcon reprend toutes mes
idées c'est mon programme qui reprend et
aujourd'hui ce programme serait pas du
tout le vôtre
au
programme du maquereau et c'était cela
dit ajoutant le problème de l a dit
qu'on n'arrive pas à le suivre lui aussi
de noix je suis donné le tournis
les 15 heures avec un jour d'activité
pour une régate est du reste
effectivement il était d'apprendre dans
le projet des républicains et puis texte
a un peu touché sur sa gauche il n'a pas
abandonné finalement c'est bien sûr jean
prat a abandonné du tout fera peut-être
pas tout casser mais elle n'a pas
mentionné la réforme des retraites un
jour il est contre le nucléaire et
fermer fessenheim le lendemain ils nous
annoncent la fermeture de 13 centrales
nucléaires et puis hop y décide avant
les élections l'ouverture de la création
de six paires plus huit autres
c'est demain que les mix énergétique on
ne sait pas à quoi s'en tenir avec c'est
un peu la difficulté du dialogue là
aussi on peut améliorer la lisibilité de
son projet à propos de fermetures vais
rester bien sûr françois patry on va
rejoindre vincent roux est ce que vous
êtes là vincent roux
façon vous avez précisément une question
à olivier marc l'ex sur une centrale
mais pas nucléaire ça cela on vous
écoute oui c notamment la centrale de
saint-avold dans les centrales à charbon
dont
le gouvernement a annoncé la réouverture
pour pallier les problèmes énergétiques
qui risque de se poser cet hiver est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée
à ce que vous approuvez cette mesure
heureusement qu'on n'a pas fait une
révision de la constitution pour
inscrire l'écocide parce que sinon il
faudrait poursuivre devant la justice
pénale ce gouvernement ce serait un
crime déco side voilà donc si tu savais
tout aberrant tout ça c'est de la faute
fectivement de la pression qu'on fait
peser des écologistes dans ce pays de
leur suivisme sur sur l'allemagne tout
ça est totalement irresponsable
effectivement j'aurais préféré qu'on
garde quand garde fait sur le sujet de
l'énergie il ya un sujet qui est très
important sur lesquels on insistera
auprès du gouvernement c'est que les
gouvernements fassent preuve il paraît
qu'on a le président de l'union
européenne en exercice moi j'aimerais
qu'il prenne une mesure immédiate pour
qu'on arrête de lier le prix de
l'électricité produite en france sur le
prix du gaz c'est une règle
communautaire totalement aberrante qui
veut ça
les français sont confrontés à une
envolée du prix de l'électricité
beaucoup de nos pme
beaucoup de nos pme riche le maire
citant de rester sur le carreau parce
que leur facture d'électricité multiplié
par cinq ou six donc ça va ça veut dire
fin de partie pour beaucoup d'entre aide
à fin d'année si s'il n'y a pas de
solution qui apporte et donc il faut
trouver une solution revenir soit un
tarif réglementé y compris pour les
entreprises en tout cas
des si 17 des liaisons folle des prix du
gaz électricité qu'on a concédé aux
allemands au lobbying des allemands qui
ne venaient pas que notre administration
notre part dans notre entreprise nos
entreprises un avantage de compétitivité
vincent est toujours avec nous vous avez
une question
oui une autre question qui fait kiffer
qui fait écho aux débats précédents sur
les fonctionnaires c'est une proposition
de pap ndiaye a chez un confrère du
parisien qui propose de compenser les
absences de moins de quinze jours les
absences des professeurs de moins de
quinze jours de l'effet rend la
professeure d'histoire qu'ils seraient
absents serait remplacé par un prof de
français qui ferait double dose de cours
de français pour citer le ministre et
puis quand le prof d'histoire
reviendrait revenant revient bien il
ratera près tous ses cours sur les
horaires du cours d'eau des cours du
prof de français c'est un exemple est ce
que ça vous paraît une bonne idée une
idée qui va dans le sens de la
rationalisation justement ou bien est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec les
syndicats d'enseignants qui manifestent
en tous les cas une incompréhension par
rapport à cette proposition merci
olivier marleix que malheureusement on
va pas pouvoir refaire toute l'éducation
nationale c'est un chantier considérable
que tu attends mais je sur cette
question a occulté ce soit par un peu un
peu baroque exprimer exprimer comme ça
évidemment
quand l'exemple marche à peu près entre
profs d'histoire de prof de lettres qui
peuvent à la rva sur la lune mais après
ça peut être un peu plus cabossé moins
de profs de français de remplacer le
prof de français professeur de français
comme le prof de on se souvient je sais
que c'est pas facile à comprendre et
bien il prend les heurts du du prof de
français pour rattraper fortement on
remplace pas qu'elles ont bouleversés
ont bouleversé calendrier bon ce feu je
pense j'ai pas d'idée en tout cas le le
très précis sur ce sujet le fait est que
les absences non remplacées sont
aujourd'hui un problème absolument
dramatique dans l'éducation nationale et
qu'il faut trouver des solutions donc là
aussi je pense qu'il ya besoin de
concertation entre l'administration et
les syndicats c'est bien si la
concertation et dialogue devient le
maître mot dans ce pays
j'ai vu qu'il fait des propositions sur
l'autonomie de recrutement je pense que
je pense que c'est une piste totalement
totalement indispensable on a
aujourd'hui des systèmes de recrutement
ou des deux fonctionnaires ne peuvent
pas muté d'un département à l'autre
d'une région à l'autre c'est totalement
moyenâgeux il faut le il faut le
révolutionner mais là aussi ça se fait
dans la concertation et c'est un énorme
chantier merci beaucoup d'abord françois
patriat et merci beaucoup olivier moulin
que c'était peut-être votre première
grande émission d'une heure depuis que
vous avez été élu et en effet
félicitations d'avoir pris la présidence
du groupe lr à l'assemblée françois
patriat bon retour au sénat merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis dans audition
publique demain évidemment émission
spéciale pour suivre l'élection du ou de
la présidente de l'assemblée nationale
sur lcp tout l'après-midi bonne journée
à vous à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]